E aí
[Música]
Você já pensou
como se fosse um assunto só num simples
barco mar eu sinto um coração boca razão
sem se perder implings amentos respire
fundo bem contra paz pois o caminho é
você que faz enquanto sol derbilhar eu
vou fazer uma não melhor avó viu que
ficou deixe para trás não
o Google o medo é
Oi e já pensou se fossemos nós sorriso
sou cabelos ao vento um coração pouca
raça sem se perder em pensamentos
respire fundo encontra mais pois o
carinho é você que faz quando sol a
brilhar vou fazer o meu viu que ficou
deixe para trás
o backup do Google o medo enquanto isso
mais belas errado de caixa de sapato é
muito lixo mais do que tamanho da
solução aí remédio ruim ainda assim
mesmo sabendo que eu não posso comprar
sapatos vem aqui desde que é melhor para
amanhã para minha evolução vai chegar
tava respeitando a combustão de carvão
China Japão Amazônia na frente eles
estão população do padre escravizado
armar até os dentes enquanto tantas
Mariana já dando o barro pega o merendas
e salários ainda dizem dizem educação
e quantos brilhar eu vou fazer melhor e
aqui ficou e deixe para trás não perca
o fogão com medo Estenda sua mão Abra o
seu coração peço perdão reforça sua
oração eu tive o pensamento bom siga seu
dom espalhar a semente do bem reggae
mais Estenda sua mão Abra o teu coração
peço perdão Reforce sua oração eu tive o
pensamento bom siga seu dom Não deixe o
seu sol parar de brilhar
[Música]
E aí
a Cada um carrega um sol muito grande
dentro de si
[Música]
e basta olhar para ganhar para ele estar
aí obrigada
[Música]
e enquanto sol puder brilhar
e quem dirá Como será o amanhã
[Música]
eu não quero saber
é o que vai acontecer
e Feche seus olhos e escute o silêncio
sinta seu coração bater
e a felicidade invade o peito terá uma
explicação o presente tirar
o Hulk se deve fazer
o e aprender a contudo que a acontecer
bom então um abraço e forte você para um
jeito de achar a solução
a felicidade invade o peito terá uma
explicação existirá o amanhã
E aí
[Música]
G1
se interar seguro
E aí
Oi Júlia vejo tchau tchau
[Música]
se existir algum amanhã
E aí
o vídeo existiram amanhã e
[Música]
E aí
é você que tá em casa aí faça uma
respiração um pouco mais profunda
aproveite o presente
e aproveite o momento e
e você pode se mudar o pensamento só
você pode me ver o que sente aí dentro
deixa o coração falar não deixe o medo
te calar se ouvir essa canção ainda
tempo
e deixa doce desse pa que vaco vendo
e a verdade irá dizer o melhor a se
fazer pode chover relampejar pode cair e
levantar não deixe achar mattra pagar
para beijar pode cair levantar' não
deixa eu te amar se apagar a
o hotel melhor é o meu melhor o teu
melhor é o meu melhor você pode sim
mudar o pensamento
é só você pode viver desde o coração
falar não deixe o medo de calar-se ouvir
essa canção ainda tempo deixa do se
dissipar que vá com vento a verdade irá
dizer o melhor a se fazer pode chover
beijar pode cair e levantar não deixar
já pagar pode chover pode cair levantar'
não deixar
a pagar um
e eu tenho melhor é o meu melhor o teu
milhão Flávio Moraes ele tá bom
E aí
[Música]
o estilo manhã é o meu melhor
E aí
[Música]
é tão simples quanto fazer as pazes
consigo comigo
a elevar tão lindo tão leve tão de bem
mais fluido e comece por onde está e
leve
e ela é leve te levar e leve e leve que
levar tão simples quanto fazer as pazes
consigo comigo elevado não fácil de um
leve tão simples e bem mais fluido
e comece
e onde está e leve e leve e levar e leve
é leve elevar Acima das Barreiras do
Medo enxergar além das funções amor é
maior do que qualquer segredo é sentir
soltar as invenções amor enxerga cima
das Barreiras do Medo enxergar além das
ilusões ator é maior do que qualquer
segredo é sentir todas as invenções amor
por favor mais leve ela é leve e levar
e ele leve
o Relâmpago vi
Oi beleza
[Música]
E aí